puis si vous voulez donner un
prolongement à la fête de la musique
d'hier soir vous prenez tout de suite
c'est la direction du plessis robinson
l'accordéon il joue la nostalgie retour
au temps des guinguettes qui vibre
encore quand andrieu qu'un créé en 1848
le grand arbre en hommage à robinson
il ne savait pas que l'esprit guinguette
embraserait la foule des parisiens du
second empire et de ce début de siècle
une véritable architecture populaire et
précaires a surgi sur l'actuelle ville
plessis robinson
il reste encore quelques vestiges
jalousement gardé par les acteurs eux
mêmes de ces fêtes de mickeal où la joie
de vivre
rip et le solde de gore
après tout d'un gars qui a été acheté
par nos parents en 1922
ça s'appelle avant qu'il ne l'achètent
la renommée les pommes de terre frites
mon père l'a complètement transformé et
a rebaptisé d'un long pu me les âmes de
l'époque c'est-à-dire le modern'bar
c'est à dire qu occasionnellement il y
avait bal dans cette petite salle nous
sommes pour des mariages de vanter mais
sur demain il n'y avait pas bâle en
permanence les alliés régionaux
le plaisir est resté longtemps un bourg
rural
l'accès y était difficile train aso et
calèche pour se rendre sur les lieux de
plaisir plaisir était vraiment le mot
chaos prix polissonne accordéon
plougonven faisait grimper aux arbres
les couples les plus délurés
pendant l'époque nous avions ici jusqu'à
3,5 gaillette et malheureusement
aujourd'hui il n'en restait que quelques
vues dans celle ci
après le pavillon la faune paye qui
comme on peut le constater est resté
pratiquement intact alors notre objectif
est bien c'est d'essayer de restaurer la
mémoire du passé ce week-end on va faire
la fête au p6 comme comme on le faisait
autrefois c'est à dire qu'on va
retrouver l'ambiance guinguette réjean
sont incités à ceux à se déguiser
on va retrouver les âmes des fameuses
and d'autrefois
et puis et puis la ville va être en fête
tout s'est arrêté en 1950 les petits
cafés enfermer les musiques se sont tus
et cette année sera la résurrection de
cette tradition